So let's consider the example of this program here where we do an R and
then we should branch to the label but instead we mispredicted and
go to a divide, and we really should have executed this multiply.
As far as the processor is concerned, it could look like we first did this,
then we did this, then we finally did this,
resolve the branch, undone this, done this. So at some given point in time.
The processor sees maybe this as fully executed, but not committed,
at that same point in time, only this instruction is percepts committed. So
the Programmer sees just this as done. If the program finishes this,
until the processor finishes this here. The Programmer is not going to say
that is executed. So the Programmer never really sees, for example, this divide.
Because by the time the Programmer sees something after the branch execute,
the branch completes execution. And at that point we kill the divide.
We remove it from the row so the Programmer will finally see the branch execute.
But after that. The processor will start fetching from here so the next thing
the Programmer sees is this. So the Programmer never really sees execution of,
of any wrong path instructions. And on exceptions, the Programmer never sees any
instructions other than those that should have been executed. So
basically,. This commit is really kind of the officially executed.
Whereas the actual execution before we broadcast the result, is simply kind of
the internal state of the processor that is maybe not reflected to
the outside world, until we are sure that everything is fine with the result